[Music]
you know it's true
what's true joe
that i have the smartest friend in the
whole entire world what's his name
what's his name
banana man
action
welcome back to careful boys we're very
careful boys indeed and today we have
nigel
[Applause]
nigel is known for playing uncle roger
on the youtubes yes yes but i'm here as
myself today yeah you know what how did
you come up with with uncle roger uh
well i i just kind of was riffing
riffing that character out of my old
podcast and then um and then somebody
sent me the character was audio only at
first that's on the podcast right oh
okay i started doing like short clips on
on tick tock and people like that and
then one of my fans one of my fans sent
me that bbc food egg fat rice video and
i was like okay let's do a reaction
video to this because it's so i don't
know if you guys seen it but it's like
oh now i know what uncle roger is i'll
stay here the whole time i was like oh i
don't
we even covered him on jk news oh wow
anthony wasn't here that day right
i guess i just made that up i don't know
if we actually did that video on jk news
but i think we did see that's what we
did mandela affect me man probably did
yeah
he doesn't need us it's fine so um so
when you when you
i mean your own garage
like you you definitely put people's
meals on blast yeah they get pretty
[ __ ] offended
but don't you think they deserve it
though yeah celebrity chefs you know
it's time for someone to you know take
them down a few pegs and nobody's gonna
talk [ __ ] about chefs because people in
the food world they want to work with
those chefs i'm not in the food world so
i'll burn that bridge
before it's been built yeah are you
actually like into pluto do you cook and
do all that stuff i'm very into food
most asians are yeah that's true then i
cook i'm a decent home cook i don't cook
as much as i should because i live by
myself but some of the basic things that
they were breaking i was just shocked
yeah putting jam and rice
putting tofu in rice but he just shreds
the tofu with his hands jamie oliver and
just wax tofu into the rice and he puts
chili jam in it
or something you know
my mom puts [ __ ] jelly in spaghetti
oh oh god yeah it's a chicken strawberry
jelly grape jelly isn't that like
something like will ferrell does an elf
i don't know bro did she mix it with the
red sauce or something everything yeah
but she swears by she thinks it's the
[ __ ] magic elixir but i don't think
she loves you steve
i know she doesn't i want to try it you
never taste a great party so it sounds
like it was just making grape jelly
spaghetti but
you don't taste it but is it a dessert
or like a no it's a spaghetti but she
uses it as like a sweetener i don't know
what it's for she swears by it because
marinara sometimes tastes sweet
so maybe she adds it in that it's like a
filipino spaghetti they definitely have
sugar in the marinara they use ketchup
don't they yeah yeah sometimes yeah they
use all kinds of weird sweet [ __ ] in
there my favorite restaurants to use
ketchup
uh so so when you're i mean have you
heard from jamie oliver and he's not uh
so
when when i posted that jamie oliver
video my agent sent that video to
jaime's people and i heard back from his
team saying that mixed reactions from
the team mixed reactions yeah that's the
most british way of calling someone a
[ __ ] really yeah
mixed reactions wow are you british no
no i'm malaysian malaysian but he lives
there he lives there i live i live oh
you live in london oh it's from london
london
yeah i used to live here i used to live
in america i went to northwestern
chicago
i lived here for five years
and then moved to london for a woman and
comedy you know comedy stuck around
women didn't
got it that's all right
i'm gonna move back i want to move back
here man ladies
you're not here for us or you have other
things going on
[Laughter]
nobody
please tell me you didn't come all the
way here just for that we would be
offended if you did yeah i'd be like
that dude i owe you so much for your
plane ticket yeah no no no i'm i'm on
tour right now okay work so yeah but by
the time this comes out i would have
left l.a already got it i'm touring all
the rest of this year so if you find me
on socials you'll see my tour dates what
do you do on tour stand up word man yeah
uncle roger is my opener okay so i start
the show as uncle roger
and then anchorage unfortunately 25
minutes a lot of cheating on people
crowd work and then i come and do an
hour that's so asian he saves money on
doing both you know like he opens and he
does the [ __ ] final gets to pay his
own
and i pay myself in cash so i don't have
to pay taxes
there it is there it is
until this comes out irs please don't
look into my finances
what are the challenges of touring well
the challenges are touring i think that
traveling is the hard part you know the
amount of times you have to take your
shoes off at the airport
oh yeah is the security different
depending on what country you're at yeah
sometimes your laptops stay in the back
sometimes your laptop needs to come out
sometimes you need a mask sometimes you
don't and it's all you know what i hate
the when you go through those security
each one thinks the rest of the world
operates like that right so you'll take
out your laptop and like the laptop
stays in the bag and i'm like not at the
other city [ __ ] they look at you
like you're an idiot yeah they've never
traveled i'm like you never i [ __ ]
travel all the time god damn it
i feel bad for them though because they
have to say the same [ __ ] every 30
seconds yeah
i would be so annoyed it could be
someone's first time traveling and they
act like these guys are seasoned [ __ ]
business gurus just going all over the
world and [ __ ] at a certain point don't
you just want to go like i'll take the
risk of a bomb just let me go through
you know yeah no one's doing shoe bombs
anymore you know sometimes they're
condescending sometimes they're
condescending too they'll be like um
like so you got to take off all metal
objects because you're going through the
metal the attacker
and i'm like damn what the [ __ ] even
though you're saying the same thing all
day you don't go to the store and
they're like welcome to walmart
obviously
you should be a store greeter dude it's
like dude they're saying it
verbatim they're so pissed you know
where they should have those security
checkpoints walmart because the people
there i feel like they're going to shoot
out the whole store soon you know but if
a shoe bomb went off at my walmart i'd
be like oh yeah
it's normal yeah
especially when i lived in van nuys it's
like i don't know about that
so what happened to the woman in london
which woman when you move there before
oh yes
please split up now divorce now but
we're still you guys are married yeah
yeah yeah
got married too young man don't do it
would that [ __ ] do huh
mixed reactions lady dude
we're big on men's rights here i don't
know if you know
we immediately have your [ __ ] back
dude we can finally yeah we hate her
it's been too long man i've been
oppressed yeah so did you get a british
did you get a british passport no no i
said i still want a malaysian passport
you know it's kind of symbolic in a way
right
come in residency it tastes better is it
harder to travel as a malaysian because
my malaysian friends whenever they came
here they had to do interviews they had
to do all these things well here is easy
for me now i have an o1 the artist visa
for
the u.s they call it alien of
extraordinary ability really
but uh it's easy for me to come in come
in here now do they make you do a trick
or something
thankfully no okay what's your
superpower when you get to the border or
they just like make me laugh
yeah they they used to they used to in
the 01 they let me through but when i'm
here on a visitor visitor visa they will
ask what do you do where do you live all
these questions and i've gotten detained
before and they say it's random right
but you never see any white people in
that room you know
it's me and a few other uh black people
mexican people like teardrop tattoos you
know i'm like yeah it's pretty clear
you're just profiling us you know
you need to get like some decoy white
people in to make it look like they're
not racist
yeah just crisis actors
the one white guy that's in there is
russian and you're like that don't count
yeah yeah yeah you're not really white
you think the teardrop tattoo guys are
like [ __ ] why do i get this tattoo
god
gave it away yeah
how did they know
i worked for sparkles man i'm just sad
so you you love shooting on the celebs
which we are we all i very much enjoy
that by the way i love you [ __ ] on
jamie oliver
because that guy i don't know there's
something about him and i don't know him
at all and there's sometimes you just
don't like somebody just because he's
the way he's what don't you like about
him he's smug he's very smug yeah
there's a smug tude i guess and in the
western world and to some extent l.a has
this too everybody's so focused on
eating healthy
right everybody is vegetarian now you
know that's annoying very annoying very
annoying they talk about a lot why do
they act like it's something new because
buddhists been vegetarian for like a
thousand years
that's not cool though you know no but
when a white woman does it holy [ __ ]
i gotta i want to see what she eats in a
day that's one of the videos i watch you
know the vegetarian ones you ever see
those videos you should break down those
people's videos of like these fitness
people that go like what i eat in a day
i would love to see you break that down
you know he just did a good idea oh did
you my bad i thought you were gonna i
think you're like great another guy give
me a [ __ ] video i did
he's gonna do that when he leaves he's
like yeah oh he's a guy dude you should
do this
you're ever with your parents and stuff
like you got oh my god you have to you
have to watch this video to review this
one
oh my god or your parents like hey go
back to school
i got a great idea for you okay no one's
ever told you about this one
i get that sometimes but you you did it
a nice way oh thank you
some people just force you to watch the
thing on the phone oh that's like right
at the party i also do that give me a
couple minutes you know what you have to
do and then you want and then it's a 45
minute video
and then they facetime their friend
they're like tell them what you got to
do you like you've like overstayed your
visa by the end of the video
i want to be deported to get away from
him
damn i would have done that to you if i
thought of that earlier i would have had
everyone in here we would have started
this video and every one of us would
have shown you a video you should look
at this cooking video today's video is
brought to you by upstar it can be hard
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel when you have high interest debt
and sometimes it can be even harder to
ask for help that's where upstart comes
in upstart powered personal loan can
help you pay off high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you're more than just your credit
score so rather than just looking at
your credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors such as your
income employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you could check your rate in minutes for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score you can even receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan don't wait and check
your rate today at upstart.com off the
record that's upstart.com off the record
to check your rate today don't forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
based off your credit income and certain
other information provided on your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record and see how long you last until
you [ __ ] did you see how nice he was
though to nick he was like i should do
that i should and he slowly turned his
chair like this
yeah exactly yeah anyway i'm gonna talk
to this side of the room
who the [ __ ] is this guy
how many stops have you made uh in
america so far
chicago philly new york dallas what's
your favorite city out of all those and
what's your least favorite who's the
best crowd oh best crowd i know the
worst crowd that's easy san francisco
bunch of nerds
[Laughter]
they're quiet nerds they just was just
so quiet until i did some crowd work and
my current question was so how many
monitors do you have at work and then
the whole club just came alive laughing
monitors one ipad so sometimes three if
i have an ipad on that it's one of the
monitors i turn them vertical they're
all [ __ ] engineers oh i love that god
that's pretty funny what a nightmare
jokes about github do you guys know what
that is
no because you're normal
that sounds familiar website yeah
oh
so i have to explain
what a divorce is using programming
terms you know oh my god
you know on github if you if a branch
has a conflict you can't merge you know
that's see you guys didn't laugh with
just a normal reaction they probably
thought
they might have thought it was a ted
talk
[Laughter]
there was like a keynote speaker you
know
unveiled some new iphone or something
she wore a black turtleneck that would
have been fired i don't know san
francisco
it wasn't remember we used to go up
there back in like early 2000s and they
just had normal ass people yeah they're
all nervous
they're taking you down now that's it
please still buy tickets san francisco
i love you guys he's like i'm coming
with a bunch of new tech jokes next year
all the jira trello bitcoin stuff coming
at you
and then favorite city favorite oh
la's up there definitely yeah chicago
too you know nice why do you like l.a i
don't know just a lot of asian people
love asian food you have a whole region
of town that's just chinese people yeah
yeah just vietnamese people right the
highest percentage of amazing asian and
california this city yeah specifically
this one monterey park okay but
what do you think about vegas i haven't
been to white vegas man
you have it that's it no
i know bart likes it that's it what do
you think maybe a shooter shoot at uncle
roger he loves the vegas video oh hello
there's so much for you yeah
no we shouldn't do food man i'm going to
go to like a strip club or something
review a strip club going to the world's
largest strip club or at least it was
what they said it was yeah
sapphire yeah
they have two-story strip clubs too wow
then yeah well yeah they don't have
stairs it's all pole oh [ __ ] it used to
be a car dealership and they turned it
into a huge strip club oh and it was
pretty wild do they keep the car
dealership stuff like the the balloon
guy
still there it's just in the bikini
they yeah the balloon yo the balloon got
it just says tits now he goes on at 10
30. and in the tits i'll go like crazy
dude and the tassels on the end fire
just the person who has to sew that
together right when they bought it
they're like i think we can use this
yeah
let's keep this
yeah l.a is cool man because i live in
london right and like the asian scene
there is abysmal man oh yeah it's like
so many decades behind it feels i think
asians haven't been there that long i
think most of the asian don't quote me
on this but i think most of the asians
moved there in the 70s
but asians here have been in america
yeah you're right because out there i
was like oh chinatown looks like
disneyland it is it doesn't look like
chinese people live there no nobody it
just looks like a like a theme park like
a tourist place yeah and it's in half of
the restaurants and things aren't
chinese they're like japanese it's just
asian land there's a lot of indian
people there yeah it's all indian i mean
don't say it like that you said it like
it was a bad thing it's a lot of india
no it is
you know you gotta check your own ego
you know what i'm saying that's how
anthony feels about you guys
but the indian food out there is so good
i can't find places here in the oh
america sucks at indian food but you
know asian food is better indian food
indian food's so good indian food is the
british food what's your take on bread
yeah it sucks right oh british food you
think you have covered because you can't
smell it
the whole country just should just be
called long covet man
were you able to figure out why that is
after living there so long like why is
the food so bad they never had a big
food culture they uh there was a lot of
poverty and then they had a lot didn't
have a lot of fresh food so they kind of
excuses i know like the world has
changed don't they got that whole
british baking thing now the big office
yeah that's the part i think they make
good baked stuff like breads no europe
makes better breakfast yeah everybody
yeah you're right doesn't everybody make
bread every [ __ ] buddy even my mom
makes bread
and she puts grape jelly
i hate it man they make good butter and
toast come on dude
i think too if you want to raise a kid
here don't know where he's in london
raise a kid in here it's better for
their mental mental mental health raiser
asian kid you know yeah yeah
they feel like they it's easier to feel
like they belong you know i think i grew
up in malaysia everybody looked like me
so do you have a kid no no no no no no
no with roe v vade but wait being
overturned hey let's go let's do it
let's go huh yeah you might not have a
choice yes
i'll fly them out to london and they'll
jam a coat hanger in them it's legal
there i like it
we were like whoa and then you're like
okay
that's a great thing women get to have a
free trip to europe you know and an
abortion oh there you go
fly them up you know sugar daddy someone
how long you've been living in london
for uh six years seven years now oh
um have you done like stand-up and stuff
out in malaysia yeah yeah i've done
so many countries now man yeah yeah yeah
there's other places where you're like
because you know i said i'm in chicago
actually so i went to singapore and
they're like you know doing bits and
stuff with people and they're like yo
you can't talk about the government yeah
we got in trouble for saying well you
didn't get trouble they're just like
you're like yo they're like we're on a
radio show and they're like hey guys so
how do you feel about you know
pursuing your passion or going to
university and things like that and i
was like i don't really think everybody
needs to go to school if that's not
their thing and they're like hold on
can you not say that and i'm like you
asked me my goddamn opinion what the
[ __ ] freedom of speech means something
else over here has that happened you
know where you bought uh
no no i think live performance you get a
bit more leeway but there's certain
countries like when
on this tour we're trying to book dubai
and my twitter manager is like uh you
can't curse there i'm like that's no
let's not book it i can't be bothered
you know you have to like change it you
can't be in the moment because sometimes
you you and use the f word to enhance
certain jokes right and then you have to
remember to not curse and if you curse
you get fined i don't know maybe you get
fired maybe there's some guy just
standing in the back of the room looking
at you i don't know what's gonna happen
so i just let's just skip that country
me and joe played at some churches
before and that was pretty interesting
that just sounds like an oxymoron right
there what is it comedy at a church yeah
because they're like you can't say bad
words you can't say whatever and then we
just kind of made it a game around
because then once you have that and you
lower the ceiling then words like
butt is all of a sudden funny uh
it's just like because now it's like you
just say you are you like us you know
like you just reference something else
like burrito or something instead of
saying penis and
oh they go crazy
is the guy just lifting off foods the
thing between your legs you know the
burrito
oh you're healed
that's like a good show though yeah i
would try to watch that yeah but dubai
sounds different because when they say
like no bad words they really mean it
you go to jail right right right well
you got to be rich rich right because i
know people who go to dubai all the time
and but they're rich rich and they
go to whatever the [ __ ] they want they
poop on girls they poop
they poop on models bro ig models though
i fly them out and they poop on them
they really like it oh it's called human
fecal matter according to johnny depp oh
there it is
what do you think about meghan markle's
huh she's ruining that whole thing
i know i think i think the queen is like
when she complained of being racist i'm
like do you not expect that they're like
all white british people you know like i
mean the queen should be a little bit
racist
that's the whole point that represents
if the queen was woke that that won't
work
imagine if the queen had purple hair one
day just came out and been like oh yeah
i am now a non-binary woman
neither queen nor king just
theme
yeah just your highness yeah i'm your
lowness now what do you think of nando's
nando's ah [ __ ] man [ __ ] really i love
nando's and they overcook that chicken
okay all right fair enough you know
it is what it is hey what's your guilty
pleasure you know what i'm saying like
you go to your sneaker panda
panda express yeah you just need a
little bit like american chinese food
dude you know what i like i like um
goldberg you know lucky charms like
cereal oh it's pretty good yeah
it's pretty solid isn't it but it's my
children
for children though we eat it too have
you ever just been caught eating chicken
nuggets or something and they're like
uncle roger
hey in the uk you drive home from a show
sometimes that's the only thing that's
open chicken nuggets chicken selects at
mcdonald's you know that you guys still
have chicken selects they discontinued
out here don't they got the curry sauce
for the nuggets in london though yeah
they don't do them here anymore i think
most people here can't really say
that
yeah yeah
nuggets nuggets yeah nuggets it's hard
yeah can i get the big just like the big
nuggets
what is chicken select just chicken
tenders yeah they don't do them anymore
oh they don't do those i never ordered
it but they don't do those it's probably
too much real chicken that's by the way
real quick they're bringing back the
mexican pizza taco bowl that's [ __ ]
they better [ __ ] go let's do a taste
test
i've never had one before
i never had that mexican pizza from taco
bell you didn't die okay i'm sorry come
on just end the video
[Music]
so